there are  different kinds of superpowers that  exist in this world so for people who  are born with more of a a bitter sweet  way of being or an introverted way of  being in a sensitive way of being these  are superpowers where you're like in the  stage of the movie you're like luke  skywalker before he knows that he has  the force basically because your culture  isn't teaching you about the superpower  that you naturally possess the answer is  not to try to become a louder more  dominant person the answer is more to  get in the habit of understanding what  you truly believe and speak what you  truly believe and then people feel that  that's where the power comes from